what's going on welcome welcome in to
another edition of Market takes I know
you could have been anywhere in the
world on this beautiful fed day out here
in New York but you're here with me and
I appreciate that I'm Dion Robert Bowen
reporter at the Wall Street Journal we
are breaking down today's fomc decision
the fed's uh decision their policy
decision on rates of fed choosing to
raise rates by 25 basis points this was
really locked into markets but we did
still see some Market reaction we're
going to talk through all that of course
we're going to talk about what the FED
did how that aligned with expectations
and the market reaction we're going to
talk a little bit about the environment
coming into this report and really how
what the FED did move markets now it
could move markets going forward into
the future we're also going to talk
about the Powell press conference and
what we learned from the FED chairman
and of course talk about what comes next
because we are always looking forward
here on Market takes and that's what we
do so listen before we before we go into
any more complicated analysis let's just
first talk about what happened today the
FED raised rates by 25 basis points want
to throw a chart up here on your screen
so you can see just what we're looking
at in terms of action from the FED what
you see there on the right of your
screen the rate coming up really at the
fastest Pace we have seen a lot of folks
say in modern history but really when
you talk about going from that zero
level to where we are now which is 5.25
to 5.5 percent that's really the fastest
rate when you think about where we've
come from to where we are that we have
seen in history so this rate this rate
hike cycle is kind of unprecedented in
history and you see there just kind of
shoot straight up for the first few
months and then you get that sort of
slow down and it looks more like an arc
more like what she had seen before in
those previous Cycles you'll also notice
there that those recession shadings are
in there you see the 2001 recession that
2008 Global financial crisis and the
Great Recession as it's known and then
that 2020 coveted recession the shortest
ever in history those all tend to
coincide with when rates are higher that
doesn't necessarily mean that the high
rates cause the result that we
necessarily have to have a recession now
but do keep in mind with rates as you
see there on the right of your screen
the highest they have been since 2001
that is definitely something to keep an
eye out for because the economy
struggles with those higher rates it's
harder for businesses to borrow money
it's more expensive harder for folks to
borrow money by borrowing from you know
against their home with those home loans
and so it's harder for people to get
credit harder for businesses to grow
harder to pay off some of those debts
and those things and so that tends to
lead to a slower economy and a lot of
times drives the economy into recession
that's not what the Federal Reserve
wants to see that's not what the data
shows us but it is something just keep
your eye out for and this chart really
just illustrating how far we've come in
terms of raising rates and getting them
to that high level that you see there
5.25 to 5.5 percent where we are today
um really one of the biggest and most
interesting things about the report
wasn't even what we heard from the
chairman that's usually the big
Blockbuster thing it's what we got in
the FED statement the fomc statement
from the committee which had almost no
changes usually when the Federal Reserve
makes a change like last month they
didn't raise rates they held they held
Pat didn't raise rates at all this month
they did they raised 25 basis points so
when you get a change in policy like
that usually there's a long explanation
there's we see this change in the
economy we saw that this moved our
analysis has changed our view of the
economy has changed this month's
statement almost nothing changed except
for the fact the FED said yeah we raised
interest rates to five and a quarter to
five and a half which is how they'll put
it in their statement and they said the
economy expander economic activity has
expanded a quote moderate rather than a
quote modest Pace other than that no
real changes to the statement and that
was very interesting you really did see
the market start to take off after the
statement came out and sort of started
to come back down a little bit after Fed
chair Jerome Powell started to talk and
really talk about what he was thinking
about the market but the statement with
almost no changes locked in some of
these Market expectations and really you
saw stock prices go up you saw those
bond prices come down both of those
things mean people are buying when stock
prices go up it means folks are buying
when bond yields go down means bond
prices are rising which means again
folks are buying so that was interesting
we'll talk more about that in just a
second but that minimal change is
unusual when the Federal Reserve makes a
change in policy typically includes a
lot of explanation
um so what's next well what's next is
data dependence you know I know you all
are here on Market takes so you
understand the importance of the data
you understand the importance of the CPI
pce the jobs report all those things but
for a lot of folks who don't really
follow the markets that closely they
could see some wild swings when we get
the next jobs report when we get this
pce report later this week when we get
CPI or PPI those could move the market a
lot because we don't really know what
the FED wants to do the FED isn't sort
of hedging in One Direction the other
the way they usually do usually there
will be Market expectations for okay
they're saying this but what we really
expect is a hike coming into this month
we had a 100 expectation for at least a
25 basis point hike and even a little
bit of an expectation 3.5 expectation
for a 50 basis point hike so there was
no one in the markets who thought the
FED wouldn't raise rates today that was
priced in the only question was what
would they say and how would that affect
the Outlook and really what we've heard
today was Fed chair Jerome Powell does
not know what comes next he is going to
be all about inflation data all about
jobs data all about retail sales data
and growth data all about housing data
and thankfully we here at Market takes
and be here to break it down for you so
plea please stay tuned and stick with us
those of us those of you who have been
watching Market takes I know you'll keep
tuning in those of you having a tell a
friend you're going to want to know
what's going to move markets and that's
going to be what we talk about from
Market takes this really could be the
first time the FED is truly data
dependent it's a phrase that they've
used a lot it's kind of been beaten into
our heads a lot but folks really a lot
of times don't believe investors in and
folks out there in the markets that say
yeah yeah they say they'll be data
dependent if this thing really over
performs we get a lot more jobs than
expected or a lot less jobs or a
supremely or significantly negative
print then they'll react but this really
shows us and what we heard today from
the chairman really sets us up to where
it's all about the data individual
reports are going to move markets and
are going to move markets across the
board we're talking not just stocks but
bonds we're talking currencies we're
talking Commodities uh potentially even
the crypto Market could be moved
significantly by some of these big
releases I want to point out one thing
the FED chairman said that I don't think
really got a lot of play in the markets
but I thought this really caught me off
guard he talked about if we see
inflation coming down credibly and
sustainably in his words then we can
move down to a neutral level or even
below a neutral level what that means is
potentially rate Cuts as in moving the
FED funds rate back down and here's why
that matters is rate cuts are usually
aligned with the start of a big takeoff
in stock prices with the start of a
robust increase in stock prices and
economic activity and usually see the
economy take up and you see even more
than that those stock prices take off
and those other risk assets really take
off so fed share Jerome Powell kind of
saying hey even before we see inflation
get down to two percent which has been
what they've been kind of hammering home
and bound and pounding the table on for
the last few months even before we get
to two percent we're at about three
percent right now on that CPI but even
before we get to two we could start to
see some rate cuts from the FED he said
it likely won't be this year but you
could start to see rate cuts from the
FED that really hadn't been on the table
previously uh before this meeting so
that's very interesting he said he
doesn't see that until around 2025 or so
of inflation getting back down to two
percent so even though inflation might
be stuck around three percent around two
and a half 2.7 percent so so on and so
forth in those higher levels the FED has
said not acceptable people not good
enough we won't stop there now Fed chair
pal is saying well you know what as long
as inflation is moving down sustainably
incredibly in his words we could start
to cut rates maybe as soon as early next
year and so that's a very interesting
takeaway from this meeting I thought it
was a pretty dovish hike not a supremely
dovish hike because again it's all about
the data going to be all about CPI PCI
or sorry CPI pce and PPI that's the
producer price index but going to be all
about inflation it's going to be all
about retail sales going to be all about
jobs and if those numbers are moving in
the direction that the Federal Reserve
wants them to move so let's take a look
at what's going on in the market right
now I want to put up here on your screen
a chart and just to show you what's
happening in the market we had a big
deal move today I think I got the Dow up
here on your screen so you can see that
the Dow is risen for 12 straight days as
a closed hire for 12 straight days today
is the 13th straight day that the Dow
Jones Industrial Average closed higher
that is the longest streak we have seen
since night 1887 those of you who
remember 1987 know that that wasn't
exactly a great year for the stock
market but in the early days before the
big crash that we saw in 87 that was a
big movement so stocks are moving higher
this is a a move and a winning streak
for the Dow specifically for the Dow not
all stocks but for the Dow Jones
Industrial Average the 30 stocks that
make up that those are a lot of
industrial names those big blue chip
companies up higher for 13 straight days
you see here the S P 500 the NASDAQ both
ending the day lower and what you'll
also notice is the big pickup after the
statement was released right on here and
then sort of coming down as Fed chair
Jerome Powell kept talking and the
Market's kind of recovered a little bit
but not enough to get back positive when
we look at bonds and the movement and
bond prices you look at the 10-year
yield here pretty much across the board
this is the move you saw from the bond
market right on here again is where
we're seeing that two o'clock time frame
and you see bond yields just going down
and unlike for stocks bond yields really
staying lower based on what the chairman
said you see that even for the two-year
here at in terms of what the action was
right around two o'clock statement comes
out here and then you see the move lower
in terms of bond yields means prices are
going up we see when we look at
currencies we're seeing the Euro going
up which means the dollar is going down
a weaker dollar is generally good for
those stock prices as well and we look
out at Commodities really quickly we see
oil Futures not a big reaction here to
the fed's movement right around this two
o'clock time frame you don't really see
a big reaction for a lot of Commodities
but again this just illustrating the
market reaction that we saw and that we
got overall from markets and that was a
bullish reaction this was priced in but
I think a lot of folks didn't expect to
see that statement from the FED being as
unchanged as it was and I think that's
really got a lot of folks in the markets
excited
let's talk about the press conference
really quickly from the FED chairman the
Chairman's really uh he said data
dependence and I think he meant it this
time there have been some other times he
said data dependents and folks were like
yeah yeah sure data dependence this time
I think it's really real stocks have
been booming over the last couple months
and this was kind of the one thing that
could have gotten in the way but now
we've got a number of other hurdles
potentially in the path for stock prices
to rise but again a number of things
that could boost stocks even further the
Dow has only been up about six or seven
percent year to date so it hasn't been a
huge takeoff even though the move has
been overwhelmingly in One Direction but
we haven't seen the Dow just take off
and explode the way the NASDAQ has
NASDAQ is up over 30 percent so far this
year close to 35 percent just year to
date and we're close to the end of July
we haven't seen that move from the Dow
but definitely a positive momentum going
into this meeting and there will be
positive momentum I think coming out of
this I want to talk about what I've
termed soft Landing Summer let's put a
chart up here on your screen really
quickly just show you what I mean
because it really can be encapsulated
best with one piece of data this is the
CPI the Consumer Price Index and you see
those numbers since June 2022 that's
that high bar you see up there around
nine percent just coming down
consistently and now we're at three
percent close to that's the lowest level
we had seen since early 2021 and really
that's what exactly what the FED wants
to see and this is how the retail sales
data is looking the jobs report is sort
of looking similar to this where the
number of jobs added each month is
declining but you're not seeing just a
you know a tanking you're not seeing
these numbers end up in the gutter or
really just start turning negative what
you're seeing is a soft Landing a
deceleration a steady decline towards
more normal levels and this chart I
think really says it all it illustrates
what we've seen from inflation which is
inflation getting up and being high and
then coming back down and now being at a
level that's not quite at the fed's
Target don't think the mission is
accomplished yet I think Fed chair
Jerome Powell would agree mission is not
accomplished but we are are moving very
strongly in the right direction I think
the fed's message today was if this
continues rate Cuts could be coming and
that's definitely something for
investors who are bulls who are on the
bullish side of the stock market betting
long equities uh can get excited about
the biggest takeaway from the press
conference I think is the data
dependence and is just that every single
piece of data is going to be very
important if we get a high CPI reporter
if that core CPI comes in above
expectations that could really lead to a
sell-off and you could see movement
significantly lower on the stock market
we are just in a macroeconomic
environment right now where the data has
consistently been positive and solid and
told a good story about what's happening
in the U.S economy and if that continues
I think you're going to see stock prices
continue to rise you'll see those bond
yields continue to come down as folks
keep buying and that's a good thing on
the macroeconomic side but again a
report in the other direction could
really jolt things you could see an
overreaction a knee-jerk overreact
action in a lot of markets to that data
so you're going to want to know what
those data points mean and what they say
Powell said during his press conference
he said the FED will be data dependent
we're going to be dependent quote so
much on the data and we just don't have
it yet I thought that was a big moment
from the press conference as well Marcus
didn't react much but really Powell kind
of locking that in if inflation keeps
dropping to towards two percent not to
two percent the FED could start cutting
rates so what comes next well tomorrow
we have got the second quarter GDP
report that could like we said earlier
this week on the market look ahead that
could really confirm this soft Landing
summer expected to be right around two
percent or 1.7 percent when we get the
number on Thursday if that comes in
that's again right in line with
expectations solidly positive but not
too high not too hot not too cold it's
just right just with the data that we've
seen so far has shown us we also get the
June pce inflation report on Friday
that's in that personal income and
outlays Report you're going to want to
look out for that on Friday that could
move Market significantly if it's high
and if it's low you could see markets
really start to take off we won't be
doing Market takes on Monday I'm taking
a little time off but we will be back
with you next week so not this upcoming
Monday but the following Monday after
that big jobs report coming out you're
going to want to look into that so
listen that's going to do it for us here
on Market takes I'm Dion rabone reporter
at the Wall Street Journal thank you all
so much for being with us and we hope
you'll come back and join us next time